ثلاث سنوات مرت على ظهور الوباء الاكثر
انتشارا منذ عقود منطلقا من الصين اتخذت
فيها دول العالم اقصى الاجراءات من حجر
صحيا واختبارات قصريه لفيروس كورونا هذه
الاجراءات المشدده استمرت في الصين حتى
بعد ان فتحت مطارات العالم وتعافت معظم
البلدان لترفع الحكومه الصينيه القيود
مؤخرا عوده حذره الى الحياه الطبيعيه
تعيشها الصين رغم ان نسبه الاصابات قلت
والفايروس تحت السيطره الا ان تحضيرات
عديده رفعت الرايه الحمراء
منظمه الصحه العالميه حذرت من العوده
المفاجئه ورفع القيود الكبيره من الصعب
دائما على اي بلد ان يخرج من وضع تسوده
الضوابط الصارمه للغايه الصين تواجهه
اوقات صعبه وصعبه جدا انخفاض كبير في عدد
الاصابات المسجله الا انه تزامن مع
الانخفاض في اجراء الفحوصات بالرغم من ذلك
لم تبلغ الصين عن اي حاله وفاه منذ الثالث
من ديسمبر اي قبل تخفيف القيود 50 اصابه
خطيره في مشافي بكين تبدو رقما صغيرا
بالنسبه لعدد سكان الصين الا ان المخاء
فمن موجه جديده ما تزال قائمه تحول كبير
في نهج الحكومه الصينيه تجاه سيطره على
الفيروس بعد ان استبعدت مبدا مناعه القطيع
وزادت الضغوطات بغرض الحمايه من العدوى
حيث يتجه اليوم مسؤول صحه الصينيون الى
فكره الرعايه الذاتيه